so on a plane he could just on a plane
he would he would arrange entire
orchestras he did all he did uh georgia
and all the strings he did without even
not even at a piano just like in his
head doing this
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg
um
you do it at your house because of the
ocd yeah well
it helps still or not though let's not
talk then all right great um
to the good stuff you want to introduce
our guests oh yeah today on the podcast
we have comedian and podcaster rick
glassman known for the take your shoes
off podcast uh as well as an actor had a
long career but uh
what's your stop there you wanna show
you're on nbc right your name uh what
years ago it was called undateable
uh that ended a while ago and uh
and now i'm here
oh um how long did three years what was
it it was about about millennials dating
i think yeah i guess i don't know
yeah
i mean i don't know millennials but i
guess technically we were all
millennials yeah it was just about a
bunch of guys and girls dating on a
multi-cam and
you know and you guys like made the
switch to doing a live show like part
way through the run of it right it was
initially pre-taped yeah it became live
yeah we did uh uh the third season we
did it all live
so we did an east coast and then a west
coast wow live taping and that was cool
and i don't know why but i feel like i'm
giving a [ __ ] with the other no no i
think it's ocd because you're like next
the uh uh you know what there is there
is definitely a control thing on me
because i'm used to doing my own and
it's like let's move on to the next
thing that's right i'll let you tell me
when i learned from bob and tom i
learned from the best what did you learn
about that i could pick that up from you
about people trying to yeah move to the
next thing
so did you know the other actors in the
show yeah a lot of them were i mean did
you present the show to them or you met
them i was cast on it okay so uh bill
lawrence uh who did scrubs and ted last
so he uh cast me and my uh comedian
buddy brent morin i'm not sure if you
guys know brent very funny stand up and
then cast uh just a whole bunch of
stand-up comics and people and we were
all
i mean brent and then john and allison
who were writers on the show and i all
lived in the same building
and then that was our all of our first
job okay yeah that's pretty good
so you had to go through the process of
like auditioning and you get a call back
and then kinda i didn't have an agent i
was i was just doing stand-up and i met
bill at a show bill and brent met
uh invited brent to the improv bill saw
us perform and then just said will you
come audition for us so it was pretty
like you had to go through the studio
heads and the whole thing yeah but he
kind of walked us through it it was like
uh
it was like he had who he liked and he
said yeah the guys i like and then i'm
gonna yeah make sure they get through
them it was an experience that that uh
made it seem like it was easier than it
was you know and then after that show it
was five more years before i
booked another show my first job since
and uh you know
yeah you know you know that's an
interesting thing because um
you know
man you could be on a show like that and
then the show's over and then you know
one day
you're out of a show one day and then
you're out of a show a month then you're
out of a show a year then you're out of
the show five years and then you haven't
got another show you start working and
everybody starts to see you and then you
know it's like you okay rick you're on
the other side you're all right buddy
they start going like hey man you know
what are you working on well you know i
haven't had that show since the other
one back there but you know so what's
this new show about
it's called uh as we see it
jason katom's show uh heated parenthood
friday night lights it's an adaptation
of an israeli show that was called on
the spectrum and it's about three
autistic
um young 20-somethings
trying to
date have a personal life hold a job
you know in the days of uh before we got
politically correct
is on the spectrum
is that would have been an insulting
term when i was growing up
you think so saying on the spectrum yeah
on the spectrum means that somebody may
be autistic
is
it's the autism spectrum yeah i've never
heard on the author they say he's in the
spectrum
i don't know what the i think you're on
it the only spectrum i know when i get
on to
a spectrum is more like a trampoline
than a bath you're on a trampoline
you're in a bath
very well done thank you we'll be right
back
we'll tighten it up
we'll put the pre-roll in there
that's right so so uh have you seen that
show on the spectrum on netflix love on
the spectrum yeah you just finished the
second season last night it's awesome
huh boy are my arms tired
but yeah it's a good show yeah the guy
and the guy is like very polite it's
like that
yeah well
a lot of times a lot of traits with
autism are uh
not picking up some of the social cues
and kind of the
the
what's the platitudes like the things
that are more intuitive you learn to do
so it's cute and fun to see people like
you could tell they learn to do that
thing and then it becomes like language
becomes the way you act you start using
certain words you start behaving a
certain way and like them saying this is
so lovely and this is such a romantic
thing we're doing and then it becomes a
romantic thing because that's the
intention
it's really cool to watch
you know
yeah yeah it is interesting because
sometimes it works and they're very
honest like
if they weren't on the spectrum
and if somebody was that honest i think
people would be taking if you were on a
date i think people would be i can't
believe you would say that because it's
it's very honest but they understand
each other because honestly they don't
lie
yes you know that program the good
doctor is based upon he's an autistic
doctor
is he yes yes
yes and he is brutally honest
like that
yeah you should see uh the scenes they
cut him usually but he does there's a
few scenes where he's giving a physical
to people and he just calls out like you
got a little dick and all these things
where he's just like really i'm serious
it was before they made it because they
wanted to add some jokes he talks about
a little people's dicks are and how
so
i'm just joking
it's a pretty good show we watch it
religiously my wife and i i enjoyed
that's what that show was about yeah
it's about an autistic doctor who talks
about uh you know like uh tiny dudes
little dicks
ldds
so so are you you're not an only child
i'm not yes why'd you say it so
confidently
i came across as a not only child oh you
know i'm trust trying to work on i'm
still trying to work on it you did it
like that's what you do you go you did
it like you were guessing my weight like
you had an idea
i'm not an only child right yeah i have
an older brother he lives he lives here
and uh we're both from cleveland oh you
guys had yeah are you guys both uh uh
ocg
oh no no no no i am he's uh
more north how do you go
are your parents were your parents yeah
my mom is um
so
i'm uh i'm like i'm wondering how much
i'm censoring myself because there's
things i don't love talking about too
much because i i've talked about on my
podcast a bit but i think it's okay to
talk about and here we are
i'm interested because i mean um
i would have to say in the years that i
was doing stand-up like we
if someone had if they were quirky they
would say this dude let's do twerky they
were probably ocd or on the spectrum
yeah and then and a guy would have props
and he would use very deliberate
language you know and and he would be
like this is a ray gun that i bought at
the store and it goes like it makes a
funny noise and then he would do a good
artistic impression
the light red light would go on and
everybody would be rolling this guy
walking down the street with a [ __ ]
ray gun you thought it was just for his
act but as you see him leave the club
he's walking up the street with a
[ __ ] ray gun i got into props
recently george not george or george i
did
i got into props recently puppets i'm
not joking no
no you know what i can't believe that
you would put your hand in a puppet not
knowing where the puppet had been like
that why do you think i don't know where
my puppet has been okay also i'm in a
monogamous relationship with this puppet
a lot of people say can i see your
puppet i go you can see it you can't
touch it you can't put your hand in it
no because that thing you'd be like
yeah seriously got to get it tested i
don't do that it's my own puppet
but yeah but there's a judgment for
props and i had it too for a while why
do you think there's a judgment problem
they think it's they think it's easier
it's not easier it's it's not easier the
judgment is because it's it's basically
saying you can't do it on your own
it's it's it's people being like it's
basically
i feel like uh props are
performance-enhancing drugs for the
comedy world it's like yeah he hit it
500 feet i don't know anything about
baseball but uh that would be good
he did it with a puppet
you know let's see what he does without
a puppet
but i got into prop i got into props
because i have props i mean we all have
props you know look at everything's a
problem yeah and i just thought it'd be
silly to do and then just kind of
playing with props and just playing with
like the idea of what
the expectations people have are for
props and it was getting laughs and i'm
like this is funny but i can't keep
doing this and i'm like why why am i
i think at some point
you would if you turn the corner you're
not gonna you wouldn't put it down like
you're like
you're saying relying on it no connected
to it i'm say that different i don't
know what you mean
if you have the if you're if you're
enjoying and they're laughing and then
part of you is like i could do without
it but you enjoy doing it it's it it's
fun it's not i don't think it's a you
know
i think the guys that did props gave
gave prop comedy
um that stigma that
you know you're doing it because you
can't do it without it
you came from a time when multi-cams
were were the the comedy and then they
did this and now they're coming this way
a little bit but it's almost like people
judge the genre but your show isn't the
same as another multicam just because
it's multicam but people have
expectations of what they think
something is and to me that's a really
fun thing to play with and manipulate
because now i have a built-in callback
you already have everybody in the room
feels a certain way so i
could now do it different you know and
the problem is carrying on puppets you
know on a plane because it's an
expensive puppet and having this you
know a mustache budget dude i wasn't
even planning it i just did a show on
this the other night i have so many
mustaches george
for the listening audience he just
pulled a mustache i have so many
mustaches and before i discovered the
sticky side tape weekends were costing
me 50 bucks in mustaches
i got good mustache bits
and is that mustache did you make it
yourself or or is it no no you got a
cinema secret or something like that
like you go by ten of them i think oz is
that what it's called yes us oh this has
good we should get we'll be right back
you're on the spectrum if you're on the
spectrum
it's like a nightclub it's like it's
almost like if you went to a club and
you'd be like man there's a lot of
chicks in this club yeah oz if you're on
the spectrum you'd be like [ __ ] look at
over there look at that they got
eyebrows is that a goblin bass [ __ ]
pinwheel like
[ __ ] hat goes up and goes back down
like it's right you can find a [ __ ]
shirt from alph
[ __ ] that show alph and you're like
for the [ __ ] elf shirt
it's the best place they love alf shirts
where is this place
at one point
probably still alph was a bigger hit in
mexico than my show
you know he's starting to podcast alph
there's one in hollywood and there's one
in burbank there's one near here you
know what
how about how about this and we play it
by ear or we're played by upper lip
after this we'll go get some mustache
it's my treat all right
next episode i want you wearing
yeah so how does the mustache play in
your act i'll tell you after it's it's
my closer yeah
all right i got a good mustache bit
though uh you know i was with this guy
jesse aragon he used to work with a
comedy star friend with power over years
ago and we drove up to a gig up in santa
maria and uh
as we were driving he he he had some
props he was in mexico he had the
oranges right
so he has this bag and he's been open to
the bag he's taking out like a you know
a [ __ ] wig and he's taking out uh uh
like to push the thing and they clap you
know
and a [ __ ] helmet with the two things
and then even that you rolled your eyes
people hate props
and then uh and then he pulls out this
[ __ ] deformed bag of oranges like
they're all black in one part and they
crunch you know they get squishy and
they smell
and i said oh man what's that he goes oh
[ __ ] i haven't worked in a couple weeks
man [ __ ] i forgot these oranges were in
there so we have to go to the market
and buy some more oranges before we get
to the club and i said what do you do
man you like buy oranges every time you
have a gig goes yeah so why don't you
just
paint some [ __ ] tennis balls orange
and just keep the
bag and he he couldn't understand it he
was like wow
so if i have so if i
paint it
if i paint the tennis balls orange and i
put them in the orange bag with the
holes in it they're going to think that
they're i said yeah they're going to be
able to [ __ ] around and buy
buy uh oranges plus
he has a fun uh item for merch
you sell his oranges i try to write her
on merch
you know it's tough it's tough we're
writing the wrong merch is uh i've never
heard anybody say i was just joking
don't but you could do dudes do that big
dunlop
big dunlop uh uh god rest his soul he's
a funny guy had eyes that he had the the
bugged out eyes
and he would sell eyes um
two of them for like five dollars and
people would put him in he put her at
the end because i'll be back there
selling ice he sold ice for like 20
years made
millions of million dollars and then one
time the irs went to the show and said
hey man
you what do you do with this month it's
all the cash business buddy
guys irs yeah a lot of puns there irs
eyes on you selling eyes we'll workshop
it
there's something about coming in here
that i'm feeling now because i haven't
left the hou i don't leave the house
much um
since this pandemic started maybe we'll
get into that but
the reason is it was tough for a little
bit and then i kind of got into this
rotation and and i do my podcast at home
and that's kind of my social life
somebody comes over once a week that was
enough i'll see somebody in the next
week um so now i'm coming out of the
house i just started doing stand-up
again a month ago i'm coming in here
with someone who i've never met before
but i've known for a very long time and
there's this weird
there's like
you want to find the pocket are you
looking at us like when like with total
recall like when arnold schwarzenegger
looked at somebody like you could
it just goes like they re you read two
weeks two weeks
no but like but it is this is when you
haven't met somebody it's hard to kind
of just start
and and try to
get a a vibe going and not even in a bad
way just by design is what it is
but like
somebody like you are in uh you know
you're in a power position you know not
only is it your show you're george lopez
and i'm wondering if you recognize that
with guests because you probably have
guests on often that you've never met
before right we started to have some
young but i don't i don't i don't feel
like that i don't i don't feel like it
you don't feel like what like i
like i'm different than any like you
know you come in i don't feel like i
have
even to myself uh anything attached to
myself like a stand-up or the show or
whatever i just feel like i come in here
and i'm just myself yeah but but still
but still i know you and you don't know
me right you know what i mean so do you
ever do you ever rec
because i'm wondering this with my
podcast do you ever recognize somebody's
energy like when do you
when do you get to know somebody on an
interview versus having a conversation
does that make sense
i'm still i'm still
back here with ocd i don't know he's
still trying to spell it don't know what
ocd is no sense of compulsiveness yes i
know what it is like like if you
my daughter's in the room i don't try
and figure anybody out i just i'm just
here i'm waiting for him to say you know
he didn't say you can't eat just one
chip that probably for a [ __ ] starter
put people in people's heads like maybe
you want one [ __ ] potato chip and
then they tell you you can't eat just
one and then you eat a bag in there i
can eat more than one and then it gets
you on and then you hold the whole thing
right here has anybody had a chip no
no never oh you know what there's that
chip challenge i think you should sell a
chip
is that what you're gonna say yeah just
just one
they have that uh spicy chip
do you know that's that did you
challenge shaq didn't like shack oh yeah
on inside that like dorito that makes
everybody like everybody in a bad word
thing yeah oh is it a ghost pepper one
something like that some crazy hot
pepper it's a single chip you eat it
could you eat it it'll mess you up
everybody
told me that bobby lee did the hot wings
and he [ __ ] in his pants
i don't know if that was the same day i
think he just i think
himself no he did
yeah he was doing the hot wing challenge
and and
on hot one he [ __ ] himself on hot ones
no he didn't transcend and you and you
could you could hear like
you could hear his stomach
and mine's like that's a stomach i'm
like there's no way that's his stomach
i mean
i think we finally
i think we're fine i
[Laughter]
[Music]
richard ramirez what does that mean you
know richard ramirez the nightstalker
from the 80s i don't know anything dude
you don't know that i'm i don't know
anything serial killer okay los angeles
from el paso came out here and started
to break into people's homes women
mostly and uh killing and writing like
pentagrams on the wall and all that
stuff and see he's still trying to
figure out hey george you're here what's
the fat guy here wait wait but wait is
this a joke that i'm not getting or
don't you really understand this how'd
you catch him what'd you do did you grab
him no no i was the lead investigator he
killed 14 people locally we tracked him
down he was caught and prosecuted i feel
like we shouldn't be laughing this hard
during this story
still 14 women
i got him though i got this out of this
i tend to [ __ ] start
wow
i know i never really know when to use
this saying but small worlds
[Laughter]
yeah
uh uh yeah so okay so i i get what
you're saying yeah you know like
but dating is not easy it can't be
that's a pro
transition right there
um
you know in my in in standup i don't
really segue i just changed it
yeah but but that was an organic like oh
meeting people is is uncomfortable
dating
i don't want to lean in this i'm just i
was making more of a joke but that was
when you go to the grocery store
everything out of everything out of your
comfort zone which would be your house
um it's difficult for you
no
it's not
have you ever driven by a place and then
not got out because you convinced
yourself once i'm out of the house i'm
i'm all right i'm all right so you talk
yourself out of going out yeah because
going back into the house a lot of
rituals a lot of things i have to change
my clothes clean my glasses put do a lot
of stuff that
um i've got to a point in a good way not
i'd love to get better but i got to the
place where
i don't even know what girl's going
at my obstacles or all the women that
died
i don't even change my concerns that
often
yeah you said where he'll sit yeah
oh so
i'm the type of guy that would wash his
orange peels before before he peeled
no no well yeah um but i got to the
point where in my house is where i
control
that's where it's like if you come in
sit on the blanket you know what i mean
yeah but once i leave it's more like
just regular ocd just like don't touch
me but let's have a conversation yeah
and you know people sometimes are just
touchy by nature they come and put their
hand on their back horrible hip-hop band
yeah
yeah right hip-hop by nature touch you
by nature oh yeah i'ma touch you by
nature you know i do touch a lot of
people
had the guy with their little arms no
rapper the third guy with little arm
t-rex they called him a little t-rex guy
yeah
but but yeah when people come up to
somebody they go hey we've never met and
they that's not good you know my podcast
has been doing pretty well recently and
it started doing well during the
pandemic so only recently is the first
time i started doing shows again since i
had this podcast and for the first time
ever i'm getting recognized
and people are coming up to me even with
my mask on but they know me at least
somewhat it is very cool because they
come up to me they go hey rick and they
already kind of know the rules can i
take a picture but like i'll stand and
they know and i love it i mean it's
flattering it's my first time i've
experienced people
knowing and liking me
without me meeting them but then for
them to for me to have this thing about
me where they stay away it's like
i think that's cool that same way howie
mandela's
yeah howie mandel same way don't touch
me can't shake my hand
but what's the what is this
like i have things that are like i know
it's a bit irrational but like why are
we why do i need to touch you
what is i know the origins of sword
fighting or whatever but why are we all
doing this
nobody ever nobody ever did that they
used to have a space and then we became
in a position at a time when people
would hog and kiss when they met or
they'd never seen somebody in a long
time they would hug them and i think it
just became kind of a i grew up like
that that their my family was huggy body
kissy faces but huggy huggy buddy kissy
face by the way another great hip-hop
album is uh with family and people you
love i'm talking about like people that
strangers yeah you know i don't need to
touch you don't need to touch me i just
don't get it
why is it what do you think i mean i
think the goal for it is ultimately to
be disarming it's to sort of uh decrease
any tension like hey you know i'm
decreased tension by squeezing my
shoulders you couldn't go to the bottom
somebody sit in your car and drive drive
it out and then dry it right
i mean i think that's if i had to but i
would like when i go somewhere to valet
and that's the only option i can't park
i'll do it but i'll i'll hey man
do you mind if i park it no no i'll pay
you now it can't be easy no
but it's we all have our obstacles and
you know what did you where did you
first i
you know it's funny man because you know
sometimes people just are just
a bit
removed
and
going out or driving by places people
won't go in because they're like ah you
know i don't removed what do you mean uh
like if somebody's pro like a like
private i spend a lot of time on myself
i spend a lot of time alone and um i've
gone to places where they were expecting
me and then i didn't go in i was just
like okay
i don't feel it is this like uh
expecting you like
like a performance type of thing yeah i
i did it and i get a gig one time i went
to this place and i had pretty good
intuition and uh oh you just felt it was
i just felt it was wrong in my up just
didn't feel like it was gonna could you
give an example of what that means what
you're driving and then something
happens into you first of all first of
all we're all more comfortable in in our
own
setting like at a club you know so doing
something outside in the street they
used to try to do fairs and all that
stuff where you're just like i'm out of
the i'm out of the comfort zone that's
everybody's comfort zone is for a
musician a musician could play in the
park but a comedian is difficult because
you
it's it's unnatural like from what
you're forming too much going on or
outside
yeah where you don't have control and
then sometimes you know that murders
that was an outside place at somebody's
house where
they would some guys would do it and
some guys wouldn't and i got this thing
to do it and i i got there and i looked
around and
i was like [ __ ] this man
and bail
what's what what
you're connecting that to the
having a hard time
like uh
going out like we were saying valet
parking
i think everything is fine until you see
something in your own self that says i
don't think i'm gonna yeah i don't i'm
not i'm not feeling you know sometimes
with with obsessive-compulsive disorder
uh it's uh it's a it's you know everyone
there's different thoughts behind this
and everyone connects with different
ways but it's mostly a thing of control
where you couldn't control things in
your life in some way so you're trying
to control other ways by touching and
maybe if i do this then this won't
happen or this will happen right so this
form of control to where
it was bad as a kid bad um i would be
taking my it would take me five minutes
to get a sock on because no it's you
know you're trying to
and then you grow up and you you kind of
the adult and you recognize is that like
this is irrational this is illogical
these are learned behaviors this is
something that you feel anxious but you
in order to get past it you have to get
past it and just touch the thing once
and leave type of thing right
i spent years pardon me
i spent years trying to understand
what is a feeling that's negative versus
uh maybe this is good instincts and i
got to a point a few years ago where i
was a lot better you could have come
over and sat on my couch i'll make you
take your shoes off and wash your hands
that's always the thing for me but like
then you're in and it's fine um when the
pandemic happened
all of these things that were irrational
wash your hands wash your oranges don't
do this you know don't hug don't all
these things that i've been
like parenting myself ricky it's okay
where it was almost the kid was like i
told you
you know like you don't do any of that
don't leave so then i got so confused
and i couldn't trust my instincts
anymore of like what's irrational versus
which is rational um so it was like a
year and a half of me just like
i don't know who to listen to so i'm
just going to stay in
and
then
that gets reinforced and reinforced and
reinforced
and it was fine for a little bit because
everyone was supposed to do this we were
told
but it's confusing when
cdc is telling me one thing my family
and friends are telling me another thing
my the kid in me is telling me something
else and then what would make me the
happiest is saying this and i don't
[ __ ] know so let's just
just just do a lot of edits on the
podcast
yeah so the podcast was it's perfect
because people come over and they sit on
the towel and they take their shoes off
and they wash their hands and they're in
they're in that one space and when
they're done they go from the one space
outside so during the pandemic uh it
i really was beneficial because we
didn't have stand up and i needed an
outlet and i put so much into this
podcast i do a lot of editing
a lot of editing it's a full-time job
and during the pandemic i i would be in
my living room and i'd have my guests
come over uh and they were outside i
have a balcony and they're outside but
with a glass door and they have
headphones we could hear each other and
it was this novelty of like oh it's
funny somebody's out on the patio with
cars driving by but it was also it let
me
talk to people right and uh i'm very
grateful for
it my podcast built during this time and
i had all this time and energy put into
it but i've gotten used to
people catering to my
neuroses but uh uh if they didn't cater
to your neuroses would it make you
better or would it make you worse i
think there's an equilibrium that i'm
conscious of now that i want to i want
to understand better and work toward it
was great because i mean otherwise you
can't i mean also other people didn't
want to come over i gave them a safe
space we both felt safe and that's great
but at a certain point this is life now
you know and and
i was nervous doing this because we're
so close i still am not this close to
people but this is what life is now
right so
if if you guys said oh it's okay we'll
change the cameras and we'll at a
certain point i don't want to work with
rick
it's just too much work to deal with all
of his stuff i don't want to be that
does that does that make sense yeah so
when you're editing that much what are
you editing out
is is your ocd go into the editing as
well yeah some things then you take them
out you put them back in
yeah also i want to i have a little bit
of a team now that helps me with this
stuff and it's it's so great but i do a
lot of edits where they're not just um
it's not just pacing edits i do a lot of
zoom-ins we do live-action animation i
do a lot of bits to where we snap and
we'll cut to uh i'm on america's got
talent and we do jokes with with all the
guests and we dub their voices and
little sketches and
you know you know what i mean and like
i'll start the podcast
you know we were setting up cameras and
stuff i'll have the cameras rolling
while we're doing that so there's a half
hour before the podcast yeah that i'll
chop up to like two minutes to show
here's how george and i actually met you
know and like uh don't touch me oh sorry
about this nice to meet you oh you
killed somebody huh oh you saved
somebody and just that
and uh
it's like making a little movie every
week
i make a movie every week because i
didn't have stand up how'd you do the
animation uh shout out to tom bates uh a
guy in england who i never met i i
always wanted animation i did an episode
where i said i don't have a budget for
this but then i did some stuff he
animated it for me and it was like this
is incredible and then we got to talking
and now we work together the computer he
did
in england i send him the stuff every
week we do notes
and uh he's he's amazing he's he's he's
incredible
and every episode it's it's awesome i
mean it's a cartoon animation man
like
warner brothers did it disney back then
a civilian doing it a guy that you're
here and he's in england and then you
send him the stuff and you go over notes
and
creating this animation is looking
pretty amazing it's also i feel like
i've captured this market on my podcast
where i i i put in more i put in a lot
on the podcast because for a year and
that's all i had and uh
yeah i'm just really proud of my podcast
oh good and what kind of guest and what
kind of guest do you do do you have i
mean are they all friends of yours or
people you have no a lot of people i
haven't met i've been fortunate enough
to have people who uh
are like i look up to on the podcast um
directors athletes comedians musicians
uh i get really cool guests and um
it's not specifically entertainment but
because of the business we're in that's
usually
how it works isn't is it anything that
you can watch entertainment yeah but i'm
saying a lot of podcasts have like
because i do talk a lot about
mental health and psychology and stuff
but i don't have like therapists on and
and professionals in that world which i
was thinking about getting into but then
there's gonna be little cartoon dicks
running around with these professionals
and i don't know how much they'll enjoy
so so let's say this because you know i
think with the homeless population in
los angeles and everything that's going
on in the country that a lot of them are
mentally ill and then i guess at some
point maybe some become criminal because
if you're
stu if you're starving you're hungry
you're you're
you're a person you become you're going
to try to squid games get something yeah
you're going to try to get something to
eat and stuff but there's a but there's
more now
and
where i would have seen somebody dancing
like i saw someone at all pierre when
it's pure one imports on on sunset and
they were dancing where i would have
thought it was funny i don't think it's
funny anymore what do you mean
you thought it was funny because now you
realize that they might be mentally
unwell
yeah and i mean i grew up here but i
when i see somebody out there in the
street they're talking to themselves or
you know they're young and they look
like it's just not sad yeah yeah it's
sad i mean listen we we're mexican we
laugh at everybody but
i should do it i should start playing
mexican rooms then i think so
there's one in bell flower you should go
to it's it's sad but i still laugh
[Laughter]
but you know you see them they're out
there 24 hours a day like i mean that's
their their world man
it feels bad that we haven't done more
for people who are mentally ill well why
don't we put all the proceeds of this
episode all right
into uh my animation budget
i'd like i'd like to see i'd like to see
one of your animation things listen no
obligations we'll talk about it later
i'd love to have you on all right great
yeah
yeah we'll figure it out and how does
your mom is your mom um does she still
have the ocd yeah and her father my
grandpa was
[ __ ] was uh he was a very successful
musician um he arranged and produced all
of ray charles's music after 1959 all of
it but some stuff for a lot of people
but that is the stuff and he was this
conductor and he would uh he would write
his on the plane would we know him uh
sid feller i don't think you know would
know the name but i mean so on a plane
he could just on a plane he would he
would arrange entire orchestras he did
all he did uh georgia and all the
strings he did without even not even at
a piano just like in his head doing this
and uh it's i've learned a bit about
autism and it wasn't
you know that well understood before
1993 but he was autistic without a doubt
and he was uh
brilliant but he
he i remember uh his relationship with
my grandma was so is this okay is this
boring i'm talking to my grandparents
with you guys
um that was fascinating uh the
relationship that my grandfather uh
grandpas and grandma gert had was
is
so beautiful but cute and funny because
she was so the opposite and my grandpa
used to and very similar to my grandpa
but he used to he would make a cereal
and he would cut a banana and all the
pieces be the same size and you would
place them in the spire i mean it would
take him realistically four minutes to
plate the bananas which is a long time
to put bananas on a bowl of cereal and
then you would do it for her
so it you know it's a while and then he
would eat and everything would be the
exact bite but she would just mix it up
and not care and my mom asked her why
does um and is that
why do uh you let him do that and she
said uh uh it makes him feel good
and i think there's something i mean
it's so simple but it's something so
sweet about that because
i grew up where a lot of my things um
were weird
uh and it made me feel good yep you know
i didn't want it it sucks that that's
what i need to do but at the time of my
life that's what i had to do and to have
somebody who is just just accepting of
it
not trying to fix it not complaining
about it um
that's beautiful it's not harming
anybody do it but a lot of people would
be like what the [ __ ] are you doing
don't do that or hurry up and give it to
me but i think that's that's almost
[ __ ] torture to somebody yeah you're
trying to get it this probably won't
make it you're trying to get somebody to
close the door
and every time you see the [ __ ] door
open you say to yourself you can't close
that [ __ ] door
right and all the things that happen
because that [ __ ] door is open and if
you close it and you come back five
minutes later it's going to be open
and you're asking somebody can you close
this door in his house
is this a thing that happens with your
door a lot is that why you're saying
that's somebody this ain't going to be
on has you know your daughter right so
he's not living with him and no no
no curt uh it's a courtesy no
respect consideration no consideration
for
what he wants what he wants in this
house you're the cat the cat [ __ ] dog
eats the cat food and the better if the
door was closed doors never closed but
also like you're saying with the cutting
the bananas
if if i if you're ocd and you're a young
kid and you're back like back in the day
or whatever and you put your jacket in a
certain thing and they tell your mom
says i [ __ ] and she grabs a jacket and
she throws it on the ground and she goes
i [ __ ] hate that you put your jacket
there inside you're
you're going [ __ ] crazy in your head
especially as a kid where you don't know
your own boundaries yet and then you
start to adapt other people's and you
judge yourself and
i grew up very fortunate with
understanding parents yeah i i didn't
know if it was
you know um
generational ocd or those things but as
a composer generational what do you mean
like people are having it or diagnosed
diagnosed
like genetics
it's genetic yeah there's a big genetic
factor
yeah so so a guy who's a uh
composer who sees the thing in their
head
is like a beautiful mind like you just
you see the notes and you you can hear
them without the actual music
and you're sitting there and you're
writing out a plane and you're you're
doing your work isn't that so cool
orchestras
instruments different things just like
this i mean that's like mozart i can't
imagine
what what it's like
you know just
doing for orchestras yeah
and not having anything to even hear
just knowing the notes yeah so cool
yeah um
but uh
uh did you did your mom work
yeah she sells perfume
uh but she was uh
you know i guess relatively speaking a
stay-at-home mother
and she has some ocd too but my
grandfather
and and i
have it it's my mom is like
you know she'll turn all these things to
face the right way but all of her things
serve a purpose she's very organized she
gets things done she has checklists you
know
all of her things are logical where i'm
more just like
how could you move your classes a little
bit yeah you know why if someone if
someone doesn't understand
what that is and you're in a
relationship with somebody
it can be [ __ ] hell to live with
somebody so somebody i know
um when they were growing up
the mother was ocd
and when the dog would go outside and
come in she would clean the dog's paws
with like lysol like a rag and spray the
lights on clean the dog's feet coming
into the house and cleaning where
everybody's where everybody stepped and
it was a thing where he said you know if
you if we went in the kitchen and we
made toast and we thought we cleaned
she'd spent an hour picking up every
[ __ ] crumb or
the knife that you left butter on and i
mean and it could be exhausting for both
people yeah yeah um i'm in a
relationship um shout out to betty
you'll put instagram handle up here
where uh
she is uh
very
uh
i have never met somebody
who not only is okay with the thing i'm
doing she thinks it's funny
you know so kind of like
not only does that mean i think it's
funny but it's she no she understands it
she understands but also thinks it's
funny like if because i'll sometimes be
like i can't have like i'll have these
little like
and and instead of her being like whoa
or just being submissive she'll like
almost making fun of me in a way like
she knows like relax dude you know yeah
um
she uh for some reason
likes to just make sure that her fingers
are sticky before she touches stuff it
makes her feel better i guess she just
touches stuff and then she'll open all
the handles and there's little sticky
stuff on the stuff and uh she's you know
i know it's a very cliche thing that you
know your girl she's not hungry but then
she wants some of your food that
wouldn't bother me but she wants i'll
leave my salad and she'll eat
the the beans and the corns out of it so
i just have lettuce left and i get upset
with her and instead of she puts notes
up on the on the refrigerator don't eat
ricky's food or he'll yell at you and
like now my friends see this and like
she kind of busts my balls about it in a
way where it kind of calms me down
oh
you know no yeah i get it i get it
because it's because it's almost well
what is it through humor you identify
something and if you can make it funny
then you get to see their perspective
yeah you know a lot of the traits that
he's talking about and with his
mannerisms
i don't know if you can see him behind
your behind your dad's back but
does the thing that the doctor does when
he gets excited hey it you know the way
he moves his hand the way he talks
little things the very same thing you're
talking about are you saying he's doing
the doctor's material he does that stuff
on the show he's stealing he's saying
he's stealing from the doctor he's
stealing from the hands
doc which doctor uh the good doctor the
doctor yeah the good doctor the uh oh i
thought you meant like another comic i'm
like am i doing his material no no no no
no are you doing doctor doctor uh
this is uh the program the good doctor
he's an autistic doctor did you know
that
what that the good doctor was an
autistic doctor yeah i didn't know that
i don't i i uh i do know that the actor
is not autistic no he's not but i
understand after he plays his roles boy
or his arms tired
yeah so
but when you do that is there tension in
your arms or are you relaxed
i i i think this is just uh some people
talk with their hands you know yeah yeah
sometimes you do this you know what i
mean how now how does a guy that's
that's that way
you know not only that way than the bad
but find stand up
are you musical yeah play a piano yeah
why'd i say piano because i think you
knew piano you knew older brother
yeah but you thought i was under 30.
yeah so
miss
did you call me miss i missed
yeah how do you find that way because
now you're in a room with people and
you're standing so so uh
i loved comedy um i loved uh creating
stuff like even in college i would
whenever there was i was a marketing
major marketing and theater but for all
business stuff i would always do make
videos and like
try to make content and stuff and um i
wanted to be an actor i didn't even know
comedy necessarily but i wanted to act
and create stuff and
i went i saw tracy morgan at the
hollywood impr not the hollywood
cleveland improv
and i was a fan of tracy morgan but i
never seen a stand-up and i i was blown
away
that you know snl tracy morgan is not no
this state and it was weird it was like
it was in like it was curious to me and
it kind of got me very curious about
stand-up of
i can't i can make something up but
that's that's the nugget of it right uh
where i want to try this so just i
wanted to try it because as you know
it's easier to get up on stage than in
front of a camera
um there's no production you know you
just go up there you do it i could go up
tonight
um
so i took a class at the hollywood
improv it was four weekends uh and then
the fourth weekend well what was
happening in the class
just you know i i don't know because you
know across the street from the comedy
store they used to be the annex so the
comics or annex like in the early 80s
70s and on sundays you could go in there
and i think it was like a dollar and
you'd go in there and there'd be danny
maura and like robert aguayo and some
guys that were regulars at the store but
mostly
they were like young comedians and then
you'd go up there and you would uh maybe
do five minutes and then they would
critique you so i don't know if it was a
a class other than they probably said
you know you you're doing this you're
doing that i think you should try this
you're talking too fast you know yeah i
don't it was 2007. um but like that's
you know move the microphone stand out
of the way when they're talking it would
be uh
you know
well how do you make this poor
personality stuff that that like i guess
i'm sure is good advice but it's not
gonna be enough you know it's just right
but what it was for me and i would
imagine a lot of people and um
that's why i don't not when people like
taking a comedy class and some people
like you're not gonna learn anything
it's not just about learning something
it's about being put in a position where
you're forced to get over a fear or do
it anyway so it forced us all this
community of people that nobody wanted
to do it because it's terrifying right
so it just basically what that class
gave me was it forced me to do my first
set
um in front of an audience that was
there to be supportive uh and then it
was like yeah i like this
uh yeah um and i moved here you know
what that that's a that's a good point
but you know somebody an audience that
was there to be
to be uh um
supportive as opposed to
just going in cold and yeah on a monday
and you sign up and the guy's like hey
i haven't done it before i'm going to
see how it goes and that's
[ __ ] got to be scary i bet there's
pros and cons to both i mean
experiencing that big bomb that first
time i mean get it out of the way i
guess because when i first went up i i
still haven't done a set that good you
know they're all just like you know good
for him it's his first time my son's
going up next or whatever or my brother
um
so there was a little bit of a false
confidence
you think it is in a good way in a good
way it's just a good it's just yeah it
was just like
this ain't so bad it was i didn't know
it yet but you know this ain't so hard
but it is hard i remember uh a guy there
lee his name is uh lee hurlins he ran
the improv in cleveland for a long time
maybe still does i don't know but i
remember afterwards he said to me uh
it's going to take you ten years
to be a a headlining community and i
remember thinking thinking then
i believe that's the case for people but
there's no way ten years
there's no and and i think i've always
remembered that and yeah it takes
everybody it's almost like it takes
everybody 10 years yeah um
and i started when i was 22 i guess so
like when people start when they're
older
what are we learning along the way as
we're like when you start from zero and
you're up there and you go up there and
maybe you do good one time and there's
no but you haven't done it enough to to
have consistency so you're like oh that
was good your friends yeah that was good
next time it's not so good [ __ ] i didn't
do so well that you don't live and die
with every time you go up it's just
trying to get a little bit of your legs
under you yeah uh trying to be able to
to kind of uh not take too much time but
yet not talk too fast i mean there's so
many things how old are you when you
started 18 i was still in high school
when when because it was it was a it was
obviously a different time there were
less people doing it then how long until
you were making a living
um well you know i would you know [ __ ]
man i was like a quitter so i would
start and stop you know
and uh i would go for a little bit one
year and then not go for a few years and
then go back
and i just couldn't commit to it so i i
you know my i got diagnosed by my
baseball coach in high school that
whenever
something became tough for me i would
quit
and it was right was that a conscious
thing you know this is hard i don't want
to do it
no i just realized i didn't really have
any
true desire i didn't have a father you
know nobody really taught me that when
[ __ ] gets tough that's when you dig in
more i would quit why did you
go back and stay
and how old were you
uh
i was uh 18
24.
and it dawned i was playing golf and
golf is is tough i love it i still play
and
when i started to play golf in the
beginning
if i hit it sideways i would leave after
nine holes so i was like where are you
going oh man i gotta meet somebody i
forgot but i was quitting and you had
cell phones when you were twenty-five
that one like that yeah okay so yeah
you know i didn't have these i didn't
have these fingers when i was yeah so so
i was in the car after one time i left
and i could almost you know like in star
wars you see that i could see my coach
and he was like hey when [ __ ] gets tough
you quit and [ __ ] i never done i
never connected the two things i
connected it to all the stuff that
i loved to do and didn't do anymore
because
it got tough and i just kind of
it just kind of all became clear there
what did you decide to start doing again
other than stand up did you go play the
back nine i would play all 18 holes i
wouldn't quit if it got tough and then i
went back
to my high school my coach was still
there he's passed since then but i went
and apologized to him and he was like he
couldn't believe that i went to tell him
that i was sorry for the way i acted and
i thanked him for his for his diagnosis
of me and it changed my it changed my
the rest of my life you started stand up
six years later you're off and on you
make this realization you're 24 now you
lean in
and then when do you make a living
from it 87
how old are you then
um
27. so it took you three years of
after six years of off and on it took
you three years to make a living
and it took me seven years to do a
tonight show with johnny carson
it took you so you were
uh you're doing an hour three years in
on the road or is that not how it worked
then no you were doing spots uh but yeah
an hour yeah an hour
how old do when you got your shot your
first one i was uh 42
that's cool man
but in increments
you know if you look at it if i look at
it now looking back in increments
i had a pretty good
incrementally i had pretty good pretty
good success
and i had a radio show in los angeles
here in 2000
and um
you know
i mean
you know somebody could see you and help
you but they can't
do the jokes for you so you know i met
sandra bullock in
and she was like you know i like what
you do i like you know you got to come
over to the office and you know let's
talk and see if there's a you know a
show here and i wasn't going to go
and i was like oh [ __ ] man sandra
bullock produced your show
the center bullet the actress she's a
small world she found it
she found me man i mean she
i don't know i'd be sitting here
i cut you off though keep saying are you
saying you went to your office so so you
know you went to your office and
i don't think i ever had really anybody
that had my my back that was that had
that could help somebody
you know had the confidence in you i had
the confidence in me that where'd she
see you
she showed me the that brian the bray
improv
at one live show she happened to have
been at then we set it up for her to go
but she drove from the [ __ ] chateau
marmont to brea
to see me on a thursday and i was
headlining the week shout out to sandra
bullock will put her instagram yeah
instagram uh i have an email too
and
and she she was like
i want to see more
and you know her mother had passed in
that time and she had done miss
congeniality and became like very
disillusioned with hollywood because you
knew somebody your mom and she was a
little bit lost and the success of
hollywood is not the same as
you know you lose your mother's shoes i
didn't want to act and then when she saw
me
she said that she saw somebody that was
happy for just even the most
little bit of things going forward like
i mean she goes you you re
ignited
[Music]
the thing in me that that made me want
to be an actress was that you
were so happy about just the the
smallest thing going your way and she
said i had to see where that would go
what set were you doing where you were
talking about gratitude like that
um
i wasn't i was just doing stuff about
growing up and she saw you being
grateful in it like as subtext no no she
saw the the kind of like that the the
whole relationship with the mom and
relations with the grandmother
relationship but you're saying she saw
you being happy about little things oh
as we started to work together gotcha
why did she come see you what was it
that like you know she she had a partner
this guy jonathan that would go out and
they were trying to do shows trying to
produce shows and she tried to produce a
couple shows and it didn't work so when
she took a break from acting she thought
well maybe i'll try to find somebody and
produce a show and the two you know the
two things that she had done didn't work
and she saw me and it worked and then
with her going to all the tapings and
being you know if she was in new york
and we were casting you know we we'd
feed her in and she'd see or she'd feed
her we'd feed her in was she ever on the
show yeah
and she was on the show
uh how far which is pretty crazy man
because that it's like that one person
that
doesn't know you doesn't but she sees
what you are
and sees the joy in somebody and says
i i i i got to do this and it and it
changed her it changed us
that was the story bill lawrence came to
the improv to see brent my friend brent
but i was on the show too and it was the
same story he he gave me a first job and
it was just some guy that champions you
for some reason um it wasn't even the
greatest set in the world it was
actually a very weird set uh he came up
to me and he said i love how comfortable
you are in uncomfortable moments and i
remember thinking i loved that he
appreciated me but i but what was
uncomfortable
yeah you know like this was funny it was
i did it on purpose um but yeah it just
takes one champion who has
an ability to help you and then decide
to help you right and in the way that
you prepared your material
was was it a lot of
putting things in and out or did you
commit to something or did you i i used
to i still do but i'm i'm trying to fix
it i used to um
i have a problem lying um
i have a problem lying uh for a lot of
reasons uh mostly it just it's too hard
to keep track of and
sometimes i do things that feel like a
lie even if they're not i've talked
about my podcast a lot but the how was
your weekend good i was here like just
i'm lying to about my interest of yours
i'm lying about telling you good if it
was it just makes me uncomfortable so i
i try to avoid that but isn't that what
the just the way that people
unfortunately greet each other and it's
like have a good day yeah have a good
day is fine thanks
hey how was what how was how was your
quarantine
yeah it's like what do you want me to
tell you man i have to get put into an
act yeah i don't know it was sucked yeah
it's awful but i don't want it it just
feels disingenuous it feels right
it's not and it's not small talk it's
disingenuous
it depends on everyone has their own
intentions they all want to connect in
the ways they do but can you tell when
someone's lying yes yes what do they do
is it in your training and police
training look up into the left
yes up to the left whether it's lying or
recalling they do
yeah when you're actually accidentating
you're trying to make something up or
you're accessing something that is but
if you're recalling a memory it's up and
to the right it depends if you're right
hand or left then it works just the
opposite for either hand
wow
that's in all humans what the [ __ ] is
that they ask me that again again is
that in all humans
tell me we'll be right back after a word
99 of people are the same way
wow man that's
recalling fabricating totally who
created who created the the lie detector
test
because that that again is like when
you're uncomfortable your body might
heat up or you know this [ __ ] hand
you know and you're like
kinesik's indicative of deception
right that's what it's called what do
you say kinesics and negative deception
thank you cid kid physiological changes
your body goes through that you have no
control over just does it ramirez was a
was a finger tapper
and when you take his anxiety level up
like the horse races are gone wow some
people are toe tappers some people yawn
some people
you know
just stretch right mouth tell about that
time you were [ __ ] with him about his
growing up and he started to
yeah yeah he started we were talking to
him who's him richard
serial killer nightstalker and talking
should get him on the pod
i would but we'd have to resurrect him
he's dead
i'm sorry oh don't be sorry about it i
don't know okay
you know you know how much people hated
him he died and he served 20 years in
prison and people were like he didn't
[ __ ] do enough time he was [ __ ]
dead
he died but we started talking about
his sister and the relationship between
his sister and his dad and i start
raising his anxiety level he started
getting upset he had his head head down
the table his fists were like this and
all of a sudden
he starts sucking in there almost to the
point of hyperventilation
his hands started coming up
so for a millisecond there i was
concerned this guy was gonna start
levitating because he was
he was into satanism
and then i real no no he's just human
he'll be right so but he couldn't deal
with it no he couldn't deal with it was
but i was pushing those buttons too i'll
tell you this this was on my podcast
we're animating he's levitating and i'm
gonna say hold on one second i'm gonna
i'm gonna and then i'm gonna get a
reaction shot of me going
and then be like i'm sorry so so your
sister
we went from that to hey you want to
take a break you want something to eat
let's get and we got him some food is
that
and why do police uh
take somebody to like mcdonald's after
they arrest him gain trust come on dude
what do you know
it doesn't matter where you're at
whatever they want sorry whatever they
want i took killer uh get them i've
taken them to get burritos they're
mexican i'm going to get them a
hamburger yeah because you're building
you're
you're just building a bag before yeah
let's see
cheat a guy like you'd like to be
treated if you were in his shoes
don't take much doesn't mean i love him
i'll take him out to dinner later on he
just and his good good cop bad cop uh uh
a procedure in police work the only way
the guy goes like [ __ ] him so anyways um
that only works with new guys that
haven't been involved in law yeah they
haven't been involved in the law
could we do it could we do a little good
cup back up with him yeah
all right
that's a nice hat you're wearing it's
not a nice hat it's a [ __ ] trash hat
what'd you do last night don't listen to
him what does it look you think i'm
gonna answer your [ __ ] question do
you see a pee on my forehead i ain't
open there yeah i can't do this i'm
sorry um maybe i'll i'm sorry i'll be
good competition because he knows if he
touches you you're gonna [ __ ] run off
yeah like in the cartoons you're going
through the wall and you're
shaking
that's good merch
people always
a hole in a mountain for a train tracks
whatever you got it coyote violet coyote
uh um but i was talking about that
because i had this thing where when i i
always assume that the audience has seen
me before um
not not just
that's just the the
process so by that they've seen this
already so when i'm doing it again i'm
lying um now that's not what the craft
is you have to master something and it's
okay to try things again but i would
always be uncomfortable because
a lot of a lot of
devices and storytelling is recalling
stuff as if you're just recalling it and
i'm not just recalling it this was all
planned and
the fact that they know that i'm no
longer a step ahead of them
which
i always find that if i'm not in the
audience with them then it's hard for me
to be present
does that make sense like if i know
everything i'm gonna say
then i'm just
i'm not really having these memories
right
do you do
everything at the same every time no so
what i used to do is just constantly be
doing new stuff writing new new things
constantly constantly constantly
constantly and that was cool because i
got good at writing stuff and trying new
stuff but i was never curating i i think
of um i said this on my podcast once i
had this realization and
i kind of there's only so many jokes in
the world and they all exist it's just
if you could see them right right so
there's a moment that you're on and and
i look at jokes like bricks and like i
got one and and you take them and i
would find these bricks so much that
uh yeah and then you know you you you
just know that true it's almost like
when you're making money and you feel
like you don't need to save it
but the the art is taking those bits and
building a foundation on something and
it was the first eight years i wasn't
doing that i got great at writing bits i
bad at structuring them so it's only the
past few years that i started doing that
in the first eight years where you were
just
trying to find the
i was playing yeah very experimental oh
lots of weird stuff a lot of character
stuff um
the the the set that bill came to at the
i'm so good no go ahead um it was uh me
uh it was just an eight minute set and i
did the uh a drawn out monologue of
fresh i did my uh will smith impression
and i turn around and i get in the
character for way too long so it's like
two minutes of silence and i turn back
and i do the monologue of when his
father left and i got to tell you
something destroyed it crying in
beautiful not an impression of will but
a performance of that scene and that was
the that's not funny there was no setup
to it it was just
but in the middle of an in the middle of
a set where who's this guy he does a six
minute impression of will smith that
kind of stuff i'm not gonna ever do that
again
but something about in the moment i'm
going on stage i just re-watched that
scene i know the words like i want to do
will smith today
there's nothing to build you know what i
mean it's just being silly
so i the first eight years was me
practicing performing committing
not being affected by the audience yeah
yeah your theater background yeah yeah
is that in the world is that in the
fresh prince the scene where
his father i've ever seen it oh iconic
it's it's gonna cry every time oh [ __ ]
you know what i'm gonna send you a
performance of me doing it i bet you
you'll cry and then you'll watch the
will one wow we'll put up a clip yeah i
have one yeah if you've got something
why should i be mad
at least say goodbye this time
i'm just mad i wasted my money buying
this stupid present
hey you know what it it
there's nothing to do you know it's not
like i'm five years old waiting up every
night asking mom when's dad coming home
who needs them
hey he wasn't there to teach me how to
shoot my first hoop but i learned didn't
i got pretty damn good too didn't i
uncle phil
yes
got through my first date without him i
learned how to drive without him i had
14 birthdays he never even sent me a
card to hell with him
[Music]
you know what uncle phil i'm gonna get
through college without him i'm gonna
get me a great job without him i'm gonna
marry me a beautiful honey and i'm gonna
have to be a whole bunch of kids and
have a better father than he ever could
be there ain't a damn thing you can
teach me but i love my kids
[Music]
how come you don't want me man
okay you don't want me mr rickers
mr rickers
you
i thought you were you are sad real sad
i might
my heart hurt for that
that was incredible that was episode 100
i'll take your shoes but would you
produce someone else's podcast or you
can only do you can only care that much
about yourself my girlfriend has been
helping me produce mine um
and we we have this idea of we want to
do that but i mean it i'm
i'm so in the weeds on mine it would be
hard but it would be nice if i get to
the point where
i could hire more people
and still be a producer and manage this
but did you hire more people would you
micromanage them or would you trust that
yeah well i would have to at first what
i'm so grateful for now which taken so
long is i have a couple of guys that
help children prepare your opinions
again where now he's just it's so big
we uh uh
you find people that
they're not better there are so many
people that we that you that everyone
works with they're not better or worse
they're just different and they don't
necessarily work in your voice is it
jazz is is it is it jazzy it's jazzy for
me in the moment not in post i have
rules in post okay
we play here
but then in po you know we're levitating
we're doing whatever but then in post
there's certain formats and things that
i want people to do i'm getting a little
insecure talking about this now i feel
this what did you expect when you
started what did you aspire to do what
was what was the big thing for you i
wanted to direct my direct you want to
do it i want to i want to create stuff
and to me it was always the vision of
directing stuff i want to be in it i
think you'd be a good director thank you
because i think you'd see everything in
the mic i think no no
but i think that you would i think that
you would see everything like almost
like your grandfather did like in his in
your in your head and
and when you show up even though you
show up and they're like this guy
prepared you have it in your head
that's what my podcast my podcast has
been great practice for that yeah and
i've been doing it i've been learning
how to talk to tons of different people
some that i know well some that i don't
know to get this thing that i like and i
found this team of people that
understand the way i want to do it plus
they have their own things they add to
it so what i've been able to do the past
few months maybe even more than is not
micromanage as much
which is the goal it's tough but you
have to find somebody you have to find
people you trust and
there's so everybody has different
intuition it's hard to find and also you
know now because there's so many more
things to do you don't know if you find
somebody and you guys connect that that
person wouldn't leave to do something
else like back in the day you you since
there were less things to do if you had
somebody that you worked with more
likely they would stay with you
especially if you got along that they
would stay with you but now
if you um have somebody with you and
you're great and you have the whole vibe
that they leave because they either want
to do their own thing or you know
they're not that connected to you as
much as you're connected to them i've
made a point and i i over communicate it
um but i feel it's better than the
opposite of checking in with the people
that i work with all the time and
letting them know because i was losing
money for a while and then i was
breaking even and now making a little
bit of money but
i my budget i have a lot of people i'm
paying who are the sponsors for your
podcast uh manscape no i don't have man
i used to have manscape um
i mean
you guys get get them from atc get them
for me i mean better help helix mattress
do you think better help is good
yes uh my friend of mine is a therapist
my best childhood friend is a therapist
and
i was talking about it because before i
work with sponsors i i want to either
been using them or like them and find
out about them and i asked him and at
first he told me honestly that he wasn't
sure um
he is in person and that's the way he
likes to do things
and
uh he had nothing bad to say but that's
the way he likes to do things
since then
he has been hearing more about it and
looking into it and has said you know i
really think i want to be a part of this
now and he wants to maybe be a therapist
with them in addition to his practice
have you have you um
have you ever had therapy no
do you think you would benefit from
therapy
i think you would cry in the first 10
minutes of therapy
i cried first time like bobby lee maybe
you would [ __ ] one other no no no i
ain't gonna be like bobby i'll cry but i
ain't gonna [ __ ] but i've never got to a
clip of you in therapy just [ __ ] and
crying you know i can we should can we
animate bobby lee [ __ ] in on himself
yeah don't do it i have a i have an
episode uh with kalila on uh where bobby
comes over and shits on her shoulder
a little animated bobby
you know that [ __ ] that's it cost you
know it's so much time but nobody could
find that that amazing [ __ ] joke oh yeah
i mean [ __ ] jokers they're they're all
jokes as part of those things
props they work they work i was
collaborating with a
psycho departmental psychologist we're
gonna do some team teaching
for the department we did that and i
told her you know you know now
we're done what we're doing here i got a
question for you
and i started talking about personal
problems so therapy
and she said
you know what we need to schedule you to
come back and talk to me on you you're
on your own you didn't go so no i did
i went to her
twice
and by the third time she says okay
you're headed for divorce all you have
to do is admit it get ready for it make
the separation
that's what she said
and
here we are
i never went back
so here i am married 50 years plus and
she's no longer in the department
she was uh i did a
they said a false uh
diagnosis i i think it was i
was there problems at that time or
that well obviously there were some kind
of problems i was talking to her about
it yeah but i didn't think you know she
was quick she wanted
she was quick to say hey get out sound
like she liked you well it sounded you
know there were there i don't know that
she liked me or what it was but she was
all in favor of me getting out
you know what i like about therapists is
if you see them you see your therapist
at a like a later game or in the market
you can't talk to them
like it's not it's like when you're a
kid and you saw your teacher out here
right
like i saw my therapist hitting golf
balls and i had to pretend i didn't see
him well you know you say that i in an
elevator in another building i saw her
personal secretary
and i said hey hey how's it going and
and she kind of ignored me i said well
what how about that like it's like it's
like a known thing if you
see your therapist has a flat tire and
you go oh man i'd like to help you but
right and then the next week she goes
how are you feeling and and you get to
say how are you feeling i saw you i saw
you car trouble deflated so i i i went
back to the therapist and she says hey i
understand you ran into my secretary
because she came and told me
and she said she kind of ignored you
because
that client relation she didn't want
anybody in the elevator know that if
they know me and i'm the secretary for
the therapist you're going to see the
shrink
and says i just told my secretary not
just gill he doesn't give a [ __ ] who
knows anything about what he's doing
he's just a nice guy he's going to talk
to him so i went to her and then i
stopped going where i did a television
you know when they used to send cameras
kind of like cops right yeah we had a
camera crew following us around at
homicide and we'd done some stuff
and it's wilds man and and so
yeah and back when he was a detective
not not so much now but if somebody if
he was on a murder case they would go to
the coroner's office and be there during
the autopsy oh they still do they still
are they still do that yeah i mean
because it's part of the detective work
to see yeah if what are you guys looking
for well we're there to give the doctor
firsthand what we know what we picked up
that they don't have the
knowledge of because we were at the
crime scene they weren't
and so when they see uh an injury you
know they they said hey the guy got hit
right here in the head you know gray's
wounding the head
and it ain't a great you know that's
what he got shot over here he went drove
half a block went into a pole that's his
rearview mirror
that's what caused that oh okay so now
you know you just
so so i think this is maybe what it's
like to have ocd too in this remember
when somebody would get shot up and they
would go in there and they would put the
strings connecting where the charts
started trajectories trajectory so
they're putting in string what you would
put in your head
like you would walk in there beauty
was there oh is it monk it wasn't monk
an ocd detective yeah and he and he
probably still is yeah i think it was
great i mean syndication it wasn't
anything of course the good doctor does
that by congrats by the way
you know you see him start mentally
doing it and then they put it on
graphics what's going through his mind
what he can see that's what i'm saying i
i think that you could animate that you
know
yeah it is did i always use a red string
no the uh the but i think in people's
heads
it's connecting patterns in a way that's
right yeah
and they're doing it
literally because you have to show your
partner and but isn't it isn't a hunch
part of like a behavior thing of an ocd
thing of you had a hunch that i had i
wasn't an only child
yeah i made it i made it i made an uh i
took it i took a chance and said yeah
like like uh we were in here the guy
that caught whitey bulger uh scott was
in god and uh
he
he had a hunch but he didn't want to go
he said i'm with my kids that dick's
sporting goods and i get a call that
this guy in santa monica is like oh [ __ ]
i'm like can i kids i'm a dick sporting
goods and then he had like an
inkling if they even you know that it
might be the guy i better call better do
something yeah
get a bunch of dicks
and then they they and then they had to
come up with a with a way for him to
leave his apartment when he didn't leave
the apartment
do you i think that the funniest part of
that whole story was the guy that the
the building manager said would you go
knock on the stories no i ain't gonna
lock him up he said why not he said i
looked him up on google found out he had
killed all these people i ain't gonna go
knock on his head also that guy tried to
play stupid and he said don't don't play
stupid with me because [ __ ] i'll
take you in too remember that the guy's
like this guy live here i don't know
because you don't know if he lives here
uh he lives here you've seen him i
haven't seen him a long time and it's
like the guy was covering for him which
makes you kind of make you an accessory
especially when you're fbi you can
arrest anybody
you know i i listened to
uh him talk about his grandfather and
you know orchestra and put it all
together
whenever i worked
a murder
it's like being a conductor of an
orchestra
and that i don't know how to play every
instrument in the orchestra i don't know
how to do
serology i don't do the ballistics i
don't
they do that but
as a conductor i know
i need a little more serology i need a
little more glass over here i need some
physical evidence over here like a
conductor i pull it all together then we
make beautiful music together
i'm the one that makes the presentation
of this orchestration
that's what my investigation consists of
hey i know what they do good poetic and
bring it bring it all together yeah
i think it is right sure that's what i
thought it was
yeah when you when you're surrounded by
people that are good at what they do
it's you know on a much smaller scale
but that's kind of what i was talking
about with the podcast where you don't
have to do things for people but you
trust that like here's what i want you
to do and then they do it yes and then
and then they then there's a harmony
that they they can help you with stuff i
know what they can do they have the
capability of doing then it's my just
give me your piece give me your piece
give me this and we make music together
but also you know in a podcast much like
unlike tv if a show is um
is good but every show it takes a while
to get going you would you could be
eliminated in a week you could be
eliminated in uh in four episodes yep so
you know it's it's uh
if you're a person that worries about
things
it
it's agonizing there's a difference
between worrying and caring um and uh
having a lot of intention behind
something versus being afraid it might
not work
um
and i
but also the more moving parts the
larger your
you know the strays or somebody that
you know yeah this is a really corny s
what i'm about to say but it's when it's
art and i do believe this is art i think
anything we're creating is art and
there's choices to be made
if you're making choices if you have
intention behind everything you're doing
it works right and that maybe has gotten
in my way but also you could do a
thousand of your of of take your shoes
off and and you'd be cool with it
whereas if you had
um a studio or a production company
because you also have to be good though
yeah but also there's good shows that
that don't that don't continue yeah and
i don't know the business well enough to
understand i mean the seinfeld
chronicles was not successful and it was
on nbc and they pulled it off and then
somebody said uh we ought to put it back
up and just change it a little bit
and they took chronicles out and just
called the seinfeld and then you know um
much like a lot of standups i believe
that
you know the stand-up is usually the
weakest link in the cast which you have
jason alexander
uh um
michael richards and man
they're all incred incredible actors and
jerry sample was michael was a stand-up
yep was he yeah yeah
he was a sten
yeah he was a stand-up yeah he had that
big controversy when he uh no i know
that okay i mean that's something well
stand up doesn't act like that so i
would say he wasn't a stand-up he did
the character stuff
i think that certainly stand up would
never
act like that a guy who's out of his
element who's overwhelmed would and he
had an anger had anger issues uh
we did the aspen comedy festival
mendoza and margaret cho and all of us
and it was around christmas and michael
richards came in
on a sled like dogs were pulling them
into like fake snow love props and he
and he came in on the sled and got out
and uh did like 10 minutes of incredible
material
they stopped they were talking to him
and this [ __ ] just goes off they
had to redo it again
you [ __ ] for 20 minutes well
upset upstairs i will have doors closed
you could hear him and he was just like
you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] and he did it again it wasn't as
good of course not and uh
stanford doesn't do that
oh that makes sense well where's my case
and we'll be right back
a stand-up would never do that it's like
you know a policeman never gives never
loses his gun
a stand-up never goes there tell you
something on my podcast i would have now
animated he's got a gun on his head the
entire time and right when you say that
it
drops no it's in your hand if you do
that i took this for me
you got eight hours of figuring that out
so what do you so what do you what what
makes you what makes you the happiest
or what no let me see what doesn't annoy
you as much let me let me i think i can
answer i think i can answer the the the
uh within a scope of that um how big can
a podcast get like joe rogan i think joe
walking over to austin and changing a
little bit in the higher profile um yeah
i mean joe rogan and like my favorite
murder are probably the top two podcasts
so if you get a 100 million dollar deal
you're the top podcast
what's great about podcasts and was one
of my uh intentions going into this was
to build something
where opposites in this you have an
audience you're bringing them to your
podcast i am i started using my podcast
as a means to build an audience because
stand-up has always been an obstacle for
me um in a very good way and i'm
grateful for it and i love it and i
think i could be
at least really good at it i'm a good
stand-up now um
i believe that i have a lot of place to
grow
go and grow and and i i have this
insecurity of showcasing myself i don't
want people to come and pay to see me
because it's not ready and there's a
there's about sure it's not ready but
how are you gonna get ready um
through circumstance i ended up building
this podcast and i've built this
audience now that wants to come see me
and that's what i want i love that
somebody want to take a picture with me
and i love that they already knew enough
to give you respect of your space which
translates to me i'm assuming because i
have yet to be very happy
and uh there's a there's an interview
with johnny carson i forgot who did it
but he's talking about um respect and
earning the audience trust and he was
johnny carson was talking about how bob
newhart will go on stage and
relatively speaking he doesn't have to
earn it right they are it's his to lose
he they go and say they like him already
but a comedian that if we don't know who
you are they're not against me
necessarily but i have to get them to
like me
so i'm excited for for that thing of
going on stage and they already know
enough to where i don't have to get out
all this exposition
you know what i mean
so
how big could a podcast be yeah i guess
rogan but specifically if i could grow
my podcast to a point to where
people want to see me right it makes you
happy what's what's the success of of
things you know when somebody gets
to be that big um
you know
you look at somebody like michael
jackson or prince like the you know the
vanity in themselves musicians destroyed
they were a long time ago
um
their vanity destroys their their
livelihood
you know i think prince had a bad hip
and he didn't want to go and get it
go get it looked at again he had hip
surgery and instead of
because of who he thought he was but
he's still a human being he didn't want
to be perceived as weak or go to the
hospital to go get it back to go get it
done again and he didn't do it and he
looked for medications to self-medicate
and then he got caught with some bad
[ __ ] but i mean to a guy who was so
meticulous about the way he dressed and
the way he was and though he was very
clean and the things that had to be in
his dressing room because you know i
hung out with him they're just very
meticulous about everything more more so
than anybody that i've that i've seen
and even just the way his hands look
like he's just kind of like just perfect
you know and the guy that
if he had gone to the hospital
uh and had it done because back in those
times i mean like a long time ago when
they did hip replacements they
you would have to go back in maybe once
or twice you know the guy from kiss we
know paul stanley and he lost a half an
inch on his like left leg because the
doctor didn't do the right thing he had
to go back in there and they had to
readjust it so now the hip
socket didn't hurt but in the process of
it he lost like a half an inch of his
leg
but he was he but he wasn't in any pain
and prince was performing he was
performing in pain and then you're
looking to kind of find
medications and things and you just get
kind of caught short i mean it's just
kind of you become an addict to
something that you never thought you
would
you would be doing
but your injury and even when that night
that he landed that plane and he said
you know they said don't go anywhere man
because like the next 48 hours are
crucial when someone almost od's and he
within 48 hours he was gone
so there were so you know they're
telling you and if you're fighting if
you're fighting that
then
your vanity or your your
you're gonna you destroy yourself it's
it's interesting that vanity is is a
thing that we choose in a way but uh
it's in us but the parts that we can
control is kind of made up this is our
like this is this is the the brand that
i think i'm supposed to be selling so
that's what you have to start selling
and i think there's something really
efficient
in
the reality of showcasing your
weaknesses and i think podcasts in
particular are are kind of a shift in
this not only is mental mental uh health
awareness uh
trendy and i use that both you know in a
good way but also like people want to
talk about that stuff in a way where
it's now a hot button thing
people are now proud of their weaknesses
and their obstacles in a way that
i think is is good but it's almost
forced uh to where
hey guess what i'm actually bad at doing
this and that becomes part of your
vanity i'm part of your brand um
i've had podcasts go out that i was
embarrassed about but it was a lot
easier to put out because there's less
to control
and then people see
because of my weaknesses people now
accept that of me and they take the
picture from far away i mean it's a
stupid small example of but
vanity is is is a good overcome is uh is
being confident in your obstacles and i
think podcasts and these conversations
have kind of opened that up at least in
the comedy world i think i think
absolutely i think that it that it has i
mean you know even the therapy that you
know when those guys i don't know what
the name of you said it was that that
you would have somebody could talk to on
the better health on the on the phone
i think which i think is uh is good you
know we don't come from a culture where
we're
where therapy is an option i was you
know i was raised by my grandparents and
i don't think they really ever give a
[ __ ] what i thought or what i liked or
disliked ever they never asked me do you
like this they would just buy what they
bought and we'd eat what we ate and we'd
go where we go and i never had a say and
saying i don't want to go there well
[ __ ] you then then stay home
and i think and it makes you feel
insignificant
growing up and i think part of being
insignificant for me was
i
in reducing me you just made me want to
kind of have my find my own place i've
never said that before but
you know i was always the one that was
overlooked you know my parents
my friends parents would either pick me
up for a baseball game or not pick me up
and if they didn't pick me up then i had
to walk and i was usually late and i was
always overlooked so i think being
overlooked and being undermined and
being underappreciated or ignored
just create somebody that will not be
ignored or will not
be um uh i'll just work harder than
everybody else if you if they don't see
it i'll make you see it and
it kind of contradicts but it makes
sense the idea of when something's hard
you would quit but right but you uh you
were but i got that right
right time yeah i got that message at
the right time because
i didn't analyze it like people analyzed
[ __ ] now but if i look back i would say
well what made you keep going back and
it was like well what were my options i
mean it was something that i liked to do
wasn't a great writer were you good at
it then did you feel like
you know you know what you know what the
guys would say like
they would say
the guys who other comments the other
comics guys they say when you smile man
like you just bring everybody in so i
wasn't a
strong writer then but i guess i had
a bit of charm you know like if i smiled
everybody was happy did you use that as
a tool did you try to smile no when you
guys write your own material do you
practice it on other comedians or do you
tell somebody hey listen to this you
tell your jokes somebody a lovely story
when i was hosting the emmys in 2005 and
mayan's mother looked at my notes and
said to me on the saturday that emmys
were on a sunday you're not doing this
sorry and i said yeah she goes oh my god
you're not gonna [ __ ] say this are
you i go give me the papers back this is
awful
i hope you i hope this is not what
you're going to do
uh can i my papers back okay
so i'm working on it and it was what i
was doing and i gave away the first emmy
for
uh reality tv
and i went out there and i said you know
they had uh
extreme makeover in an hour you're
beautiful and i said you know isn't that
what a 12 pack does
[Laughter]
you know and i said some other some
other ones
and when we
you know they make you sit in the
audience until it's time to come and get
you so the sopranos were there will and
grace six feet under everybody else's
gray man
uh robin williams jamie fogg gandolfini
uh
everybody who's everybody uh at that
time
and they come and get me and i get up
and then anne gets up and i say oh no no
no no no you stay here
what you go yeah yeah yeah no you have
to stay here why
um
you burned your backstage past yesterday
that's what i told her
i'm gonna go by myself because i i can't
have you in there if you don't think
that if you don't think what i'm gonna
say is funny so you stay here
and uh
i went back there
and i was [ __ ] scared of death man
it's 2005. you know scared scared to
present yeah [ __ ] emmys [ __ ] five
years ago i was in the clubs doing
[ __ ] stand up yeah just with nobody
knowing me
so oh [ __ ] man
i was there
you know what i
[ __ ] looked out there like that and
robin williams was in the middle of the
aisle
and he saw him and he went like this
oh cool man
i looked and i said [ __ ] man i did it
that that helped you it did it was it
meant everything
he was like land like at that time had
he done that had he hosted
no okay but at that time i would have
imagined like you're out there in the
middle of the ocean and like [ __ ] man
i just need to see some land like how
which way do i go and i looked out there
and he saw me and him doing that like
come on [ __ ] like that
it it it was like seeing light hey land
and it took away
the nerves that i might have that i
might have had you brought robin
williams and i just popped in my head
because when you were talking about your
smile i watched awakenings last night
i've never seen it before and i rewound
a couple of times
uh because the way he smiled
and there's a smile that i was trying to
like i was like trying to i don't know
copy it but kind of like there's
something really engaging and sincere
about his smile and i just
me not as an actor me i don't smile the
way he does i couldn't and like that's a
smile man and when you were saying that
made me think of him and then you told
that robin's story so check this out
small world yeah
but you brought that up because you
can't do you you can't perform jokes for
people not on stage because it'll just
make you you don't want a second guess
right is that where you're getting it
yeah i couldn't have somebody so i
wouldn't so i wouldn't test anything on
anybody
and i would do it and afterward to go
[ __ ] what you could think of that you
know friend you had it brand new you
know but i would never tell anybody
what's the best case scenario if i hey
do you think this is funny best case
scenario you go yeah and that'll never
be enough and even if they said yes
and it wasn't you'd be like what the
[ __ ] did i ask you for it
it's a lose-lose word yeah there's no
way you can win yeah cause then you go
up on stage and you would already
delivered it to somebody who's like yeah
and you just
but you know the the the process of
being a club comedian
and then getting a little bit of a bite
because what i what what what i would
remember is going to the comedy store
the last factor of the improv and seeing
guys who had deals who almost like a
secretary pool got pulled out of the
secretariat pool
did the whole thing the show was on two
weeks and they'd go back and the luster
of them was gone
like it like the the the newness of them
was removed because they got into the
machine and the machine spit them out
and they didn't come back the same like
only attracted to a virgin type of thing
yeah and they didn't come back the same
they weren't as funny they're a little
bit bitter a little bit jaded and they
just became guys that they were back in
the hopper you recognized this before
your your show yeah were you scared
about that well i i i thank god i saw it
because i said [ __ ] this man i'm gonna
work
so hard that i'm gonna i don't think
those guys i don't think those guys work
this hard i don't think they if they had
as much say they didn't use it
they didn't they were just happy to be
to be going along i wasn't i was happy
to be going along
but
i was gonna work harder than everybody
else to make sure that i stayed out
there as long as i could i have a
question for you
i came in here on your podcast and i'm
asking questions about the camera in the
seating position and trying to make
myself feel comfortable but not overstep
too much and that's a balance when
you're on your show and it's your show
but it's new still
and like you said you you you you wanted
to put your feedback in was there
something that you learned how you could
be heard but making sure it's respectful
yeah and not you know because
i then the question makes sense what
what
could you give me advice
in in in a sitcom i don't just mean well
be nice to people i mean specifically
let me let me ask because i don't think
i was clear enough
you're doing your show and i don't know
stand up for the tv show the tv show all
right right where there's a lot more
moving parts and you have a vision
that's not being met but it's also the
other one isn't wrong and these people
wrote this and the director blah blah
blah
you have to have certain instincts of no
picking your battles right and then
there's a moment where you're like i i
can't have it this way
but it might make me look okay that's a
good question yeah so so um
the one of the actresses said who who
writes this
and i said uh we're going to take uh i
want to take a five minute break
guys go i put i take her in the room
with
the other producers and i said listen
you
you can't say that
in front of the camera who writes it
like judging and you can't say that in
front of the writers and you can't say
it in front of me
if you don't [ __ ] like it make a note
talk about it after come to us don't
[ __ ] say that [ __ ] in front of me
i created the show don't say it in front
of him he created the show he created
drew carey he created
worked on shows
you haven't i haven't but i have enough
respect for the writers to know that
it's a process and if you don't like the
way it is right now then graduate couple
somebody out to the side and we'll
replace it but you don't say who writes
this [ __ ] in front of everybody
especially in front of me and uh
worked it out there was a [ __ ] a.d
that would sit there with a moving
pedestal this you know we're moving to
the factory doing like that
and underneath his [ __ ] um
[ __ ] podium he would be eating
scrambled eggs or a bagel and i
i worked in a factory and i would and
the rule was when we do the table read
no eating
no [ __ ] you can have coffee but no
food these [ __ ] would come over
there on other shows with eggs and
they're turning the page with a fork in
their hand no eating nobody eating
during the [ __ ] thing we're working
when you work do you eat you [ __ ] eat
when you're on break you eat after the
table read and i couldn't i told this
guy
and i was young your first year
and i told him
pulled him into the room his aed room
didn't look like i was chastised he was
in there and i went in there and i said
can i talk to you and he said yeah close
the door and i said listen man me and
him i said
you know
i don't like when you eat when we're
rehearsing because we're working now if
you want to eat you can eat before
you can eat at lunch you can eat on a
break because you serious i said i'm
serious
okay i'm serious
and
later on in the season
i looked over and he was [ __ ] eating
and he saw him and he put it under like
he hit it
and after every season we would go into
a room and we would go through everybody
who worked on the show and we would say
grant oh yes
all right gill
yes
such and such
yes yes yes no
what no
what do you mean no
i mean no i said i asked this guy
not to eat when we were rehearsing he
ate for that i said listen we're working
okay you're [ __ ] here in your office
are you down over there with me
i'm on the court you see my [ __ ]
lakers out there was a [ __ ] half a
sandwich
like [ __ ] you're working and i fired
him
and that guy
was pissed shocked
and uh he didn't talk to me i did an
award show
that i was hosting and he's standing
there and he's not talking to me got the
headset on and he has he's the one
that's taking me to where i need to
stand and we're both standing there and
he's not looking at me and i'm not
looking at him and i go what'd you have
to eat today
i know it's not the point but i gotta i
gotta know
what is it about him eating
um because is it do you find it
disrespectful
i worked in a factory you didn't eat
when you were working you worked when
you were working but that was a
because i think it's sloppy it's
distracting [ __ ] distraction you're
distracted also cell phones were
starting and i wouldn't let anybody use
the phone on the stage because i was
rehearsing one time and i'm looking at
an actor and over her shoulder i see
that one of the moms like this and you
know looking around and i'm like okay
wait wait whoa and that was early no no
cell phones no
eating
no nothing 120 shows any other latino
sitcom that was successful was
[ __ ] two shows publicly went on
[ __ ] two weeks
i went 120. and i did it nicely but if i
had to be tough with somebody i was
tough with them because if it was
for the good of the show and not for the
good of me so the advice would be do
what's best for the show and not bet and
most comedians do what's best for them
to do what's best for the show yeah you
know uh as an actor i could tell you
that
it's sometimes it's difficult to know
what's best um for the scene versus
what's best for the character creator
though for an actor you have to read the
words that are given to you but but as a
creator i had the power to be able to
tell somebody not to eat
yeah
yeah yeah you know i if if you told me
that and it's your show i listen to you
but as an actor i wouldn't tell you
because it's not my show
right but i'm just saying i'm just
saying like trying to connect to that
and like
i would listen to you about the eating
thing because but i don't connect to i
didn't work in a factory and my blood
sugar gets low i can't do my job well
sometimes i have to have a bite of
something that would be part of the
communication i try to eat better right
but like
yeah that's that's
i don't know if like
hey let me give you another another
thing so
we were we were starting they were
starting to we went to an airplane park
factory the show was about 500 went to
an airplane factory we saw a guy the
boss we based kind of the boss on that
guy
big dude alcoholic guy you could tell
[ __ ] big loud non-union
and uh can you say that though oh man
that's dude he was rough man he brought
a latino guy over to go say felipe we
don't need a union here no sir we don't
need nachi you know like [ __ ] [ __ ]
thing like that
that became a joke in the room you know
so so um
they're starting to kind of
buy the machines for the factory and
starting to put the kitchen together
and then they're starting to put the
furniture in there
and um
i'm in the writer's room and
i get a note that they want to see me on
the stage
so there was a woman that worked with
bruce alford his producing partner
and
there's a
a lady that worked in the office she's
half mexican and they're both like this
looking at the
kitchen and i go what's going on
and the woman says uh george yeah you
know brenda is half mexican
and we're looking at the kitchen
and
we agree that there's nothing in the
kitchen
that
says to us that a latino or a mexican
family lives there
and i said oh yeah and then i got up and
i went
into the middle of the kitchen
and i went like this
how about now
how does it look like a mexican family
lives here
and uh
they said uh
yeah we apologize
you know
i said why does why does our kitchen
have to look like
a [ __ ] mexican family lives in it and
the lady goes well there's not a
tortilla maker
on the stove i said
i said are you [ __ ] serious i said my
tortilla maker
lives in the house that i grew up in my
grandmother she goes no like one of
those things that you i said we're not
gonna we're not gonna be that
we're not gonna be that show and i said
listen
and if i see any [ __ ]
glasses with [ __ ] chili peppers on
them and everything and they both go
like this i go what i go over to the
[ __ ] drawer open it up there's a
picture in there
with four glasses that have red chili
peppers in there i must say we could do
this i have a question for you and uh we
don't know each other so
i feel like this is the most personal
question
do you think i'm over the time um i i
honestly don't have a take i think that
you know what you want and you're a
creator and there's nothing that's only
a good thing um if it works right yeah
it works my question for you uh
is
uh and i'm not meaning to project this
i'm really asking yeah good is there
something that this is your first shot
right this is your this is your into
a network you know a mainstream thing is
there a part of you that was avoiding
that on purpose because you don't want
you're already there you don't want too
much of this stuff i wasn't avoiding on
purpose i was born with a reason
because all the other shows that even if
you look at cristela whatever that show
was named if you look at the if you look
at her kitchen was orange and blue and
red and vibrant my kitchen looked like
right anybody's kitchen right and those
were the things that were important to
me that that we as a family became us as
a family if it was a jewish family you
wouldn't you know somebody walk in with
a big loaf of bread under
your first thought of a jewish person
you know and so that that uh so you
wanted to make sure that this isn't uh a
latino show it's a show with a latino
yeah
and you were conscious of that from the
beginning
because they would have put they would
have put
that and everything and you know it's
funny you know and when i was married
and mine's mother uh
and i didn't really have a voice in the
beginning you know and she did but she
you know she had that voice wherever we
were it didn't have to be in in a in a
business-like setting but but what she
did but what she did was she would read
the scripts
while i was already asleep
in the morning i would wake up and look
like a [ __ ] russian newspaper they
would be like no excellent [ __ ] no
[ __ ] [ __ ] circled [ __ ] [ __ ]
things like yourself
like like that like that like the
[ __ ]
and
i didn't like that she did that but the
thing that she said was
you and bruce have kids
and you're
creating a show that your kids can't
watch
and she's like this is this is some
[ __ ] i mean she said like did you
work this [ __ ] hard to be able to
have a show what's an example of
something that they couldn't see a joke
dick jokes right and [ __ ] mambo king
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] cuban
and all that [ __ ] and i was like
this isn't we're not going to do this
and they're like what and i had to
explain it to you i don't explain to the
whole writers when i explain it to my
partners bruce and robert and they got
it they go all right you're right i said
we don't know and i said well
it's not that you don't know
just treat me like a regular [ __ ]
person man you don't have to put this
[ __ ] in there
just let's just write uh stories
and they were trying to write
latino stories there was a guy that
wrote
for cheers that i met with a paramount
and he's like i'm sorry man i don't know
how to write for somebody latino i said
well don't you write for just [ __ ]
people right
and he apologized later on he i saw him
and he said he was sorry but would he
have said he was sorry if i didn't make
it no
we were in the same room and he's like
remember me i said oh he goes hey man
i'm sorry i
i said how [ __ ] stupid was i to say
that like yeah well i mean
but you know
you have to hold on to your
beliefs but not all of them but what's
good for the show like those things
would have not made me very comfortable
and i was in a position as a creator
that i could say
we're not going to do this because it's
expected of us
and then when they started to write
characters like a babysitter it was
always a latina girl that's a bad
babysitter and i said hey
we're not we're not going to do this
either we're just we're going to spread
it all out we're going to have different
people of different color and we're not
going to make
because they were making the brown
people the bad people
just because that's the way they wrote
yeah and that's the way they saw [ __ ]
it's a much smaller example or at least
to scale i believe but uh
well because because i've only seen this
a couple a couple of times but uh sarah
silverman recently talked about on our
podcast about how a lot of jewish women
in particular they're always oh the nag
and just like she doesn't she didn't
like that and i recognize that i don't
have a big take on this no but i
recognize it when she was like oh
right
because for whatever reason people saw
these people this way because that was
the first way they saw them and then
that's the only way they saw them when
when i was married i told ann that
i said you might you might not like
going to the movies with me and she goes
why is that i said because if i go to a
movie and i see a
a [ __ ] latino being demean i'm going
to leave
where are you going to go i'm going to
get up and leave the movie watch your
basic instinct knocking on the door the
two detectives say so this is catherine
catherine's
whatever her name was uh sharon stone no
senor
where are you going [ __ ] left the
theater said i told you i'm not gonna
[ __ ] sit here and watch movies where
how would you like us to call
immigration
you know
i'm watching you right now performing
like you're maybe you've done this
before but it sounds like you're just
finding the getting up thing yeah and
you found it when you went over there
and even the way you get up each time
you get up is the same way like they're
like a bit like a pattern and it's like
this guy [ __ ] knows how to sell
all right but i think i'm out yeah
oh it's just you're calling it back
fifth time all right but you know uh
i think instinctually you know i wasn't
a physical type comedian but in the
writing of things things take
they take they they start to form you
know in detective work you pull up you
can see [ __ ] that nobody can see and uh
it's funny like richard ramirez you know
he would do [ __ ] in the house
you know
do stuff and then when he when they
caught him
he said
did you find that [ __ ] that i took he
goes not in the house
and he goes no he goes outside he goes
yeah outside brother
so i don't know what you're talking
about i'm sorry sometimes criminals they
they
they do things that are unexpected you
know there you go
and it's a sexual it's a sign of sexual
deviancy in this case some people go
inside
residences where they burglarize right
and they defecate in someplace other
than the toilet maybe on the living room
carpet maybe in the bedroom on the bed
well richard actually asked me the
serial killer asked me did you see where
i took a [ __ ] and i said you didn't take
a [ __ ] inside that house he said no no
no
and then he said outside outside
and
by the bush i said by the window he says
yeah
and i said i thought it was gone
you know but he was proud of it you know
i was part of his cool because he knew i
just didn't know it was his yeah yeah he
goes by the window so he knew that he
would have said no i never found it like
he's like all right oh so they're both
doing their thing but also if an actor
came in
and had
like you know we would tell them not to
do accents and they couldn't do it they
would they would see like hey you don't
have to read this with an accent
and they would you know how they stand
up with the papers you know that the
paper they come in and they're like okay
um you ready it goes oh by the way you
don't have to read this with an accent
and they go
oh and they were looking for oh hang on
a second
okay
um
want to take a couple minutes yeah can i
because in their head they just thought
they had to have an accent right and um
even the woman that played my mom who's
a great acting teacher and in the
beginning and she's like we don't have
to use an accent i said no of course not
she was great i knew benny yeah she was
on you i knew you wouldn't have to [ __ ]
i said yeah that's right no use your
[ __ ] use your voice
accent she was awesome well i hate to be
time cop but i know you have another
commitment today george what time is it
uh it's almost four oh [ __ ] about starts
returning got my fast yeah this is fun
man i think this is the fastest two
hours yeah it definitely has i i was
fascinated i was i was fascinated
listening to you thank you it was fun it
was you know what man i get you man i
get you dude thank you i'm gonna tell
you that i don't really say that to a
lot of people but i i'm a little
emotional i get you uh yeah that got me
uh
that's nice thanks man yeah
i think yeah thank you
so thanks for coming oh this is this is
really nice
you know why because i i know what it
takes to be good and i know
when
things are natural
how tough that could be
yeah well this was cool um
i'd love to i'd love to have you on and
we'll have a goblin [ __ ] on you with
big dicks
you're old enough to see that now right
thanks all right how about that man yeah
thank you yeah this was great thanks
greg all right i appreciate it
you